pourquoi autant perdu c'est quand même
pas normal et l'ex ocpt était un père
d'avon l'appel surtout après déjà neuf
mois de campagne avec des primaires ça
faisait beaucoup quand on a perdu
j'ai eu des moments de doute on a encore
un avenir il est temps je crois qu'on
propose c'est qu'on pose de bonnes
questions
c'était une opportunité pour nous de
discuter de faire des ateliers d'art
fondations de se poser des questions et
de prendre le temps là on a quatre cinq
ans pour tout reconstruire
ça va donner une chance unique de nous
renouveler il y a un travail sur les jd
sur le fond il nous faut maintenant
innover faire autrement il ya un effort
afin pas envisager le pays dans cinq ans
dans dix ans il faut définir un cadre
politique propose une vision aux gens
remise en cause intellectuelle nous
devons rebâtir un projet de société donc
je crois que la droite elle manque pas
de talent elles n'ont parfois juste un
petit peu de courage
on doit se respecter on doit respecter
les différences entre nous que la droite
ne se relèvera que si on retrouve du
collectif et comment est ce qu'on peut
faire une reconquête dans le désordre
notre courage à aborder les vraies
questions et cela c'est fondamental pour
notre équilibre avec ses ateliers de la
refondation nous avons voulu lancer une
démarche qui va perdurer dans le temps
chers amis ce sont là les défis qui sont
les nôtres je dirais même que c'est
notre devoir vis-à-vis de notre pays
d'abord mais aussi de toutes celles et
tous ceux qui nous ont accompagnés
parce que pour nous l'espérance c'est la
france
[Musique]